look at Barbie right now Barbie's back
in a real way and if you were obsessed
with Barbie three four years ago if you
had started a meaningful podcast an
Instagram account a tick tock there's a
percentage chance that Mattel and Barbie
would have reached out to you in these
last six months or 12 months and paid
you 50 000 for a sponsorship obviously
you have to be good at this but I don't
think the person that is a lawyer making
319 or the person that's a retail store
manager making 87 thinks they can make
that same number about Barbie and I know
they can yes they can yeah and it's even
more than that it's authenticity so
you've got to mix passion with
authenticity if you take those two
together if you're authentic about what
you're talking about it's not about just
the hustle it's about believing what
you're talking about believing what
you're flipping or what you're invested
in